Hi at maligayang pagbabalik sa Variational Quantum Eigensolver course series.
Ako si Victoria Lipinska at sa video na ito, tatalakayin natin kung paano i-represent
ang isang VQE problem sa paraan na maiintindihan ng quantum computer.
Karaniwan, ang isang quantum chemistry problem ay ipinapahayag sa pamamagitan ng mga enerhiya
ng sistema.
Tinutukoy natin ang operator na naglalarawan ng mga energyang ito bilang Hamiltonian.
Una, kailangan nating i-quantize ito.
Ibig sabihin, ipahayag ito sa wika ng quantum chemistry,
na pormalmente tinatawag na second quantization.
Kung ang Hamiltonian ay naglalarawan ng mga fermion interaction, halimbawa,
enerhiya ng mga elektron sa spin orbitals, tinutukoy natin ito
bilang fermionic Hamiltonian, at ito ang magiging simula natin ngayon.
Ang mga qubit, gayunpaman, ay may sariling wika.
Ang mga operator sa mundo ng qubit ay inilarawan ng mga Pauli operator.
Kaya ang ating pokus dito ay ipahayag ang mga fermionic operator
sa pamamagitan ng mga qubit operator.
May simpleng one-to-one na ugnayan sa pagitan ng
mga zero at one na estado para sa mga fermion at qubit.
Kaya ang pagma-map ng mga estado ay diretso rin.
Gayunpaman, ang pagma-map ng mga operator ay medyo mas kumplikado.
Ang mga fermionic Hamiltonian ay ipinapahayag gamit ang creation at
annihilation operator.
Kaya ang ating trabaho ay gawing mas madali para sa isang quantum computer na maunawaan
ang Hamiltonian.
Gagamitin natin ang mga mathematical na kagamitan para i-map ang isang fermionic Hamiltonian
sa isang qubit Hamiltonian gamit ang mga gate.
Sa madaling salita, magsasalin tayo sa pagitan ng
wika ng quantum chemistry at wika ng quantum computing.
Isipin ang dalawang kadena, isa na may mga fermion,
kaya wika ng quantum chemistry.
At isa na may mga qubit, kaya wika ng quantum computing.
Sa unang tingin, mukhang diretso ang pagma-map, di ba?
Sa magkabilang kaso, nakikita natin ang mga sistema na may dalawang antas.
Para sa mga fermion, mayroon tayong isa o wala mang fermion sa estado
o walang fermion talaga.
At para sa mga qubit, mayroon tayong estado 0 o estado 1.
Gayunpaman, mas kumplikado ito kaysa doon.
Ang pagkakaiba sa pagitan ng kadena ng mga qubit at kadena ng mga fermion
ay isang bagay na pundamental sa pisika: ang tinatawag nating exchange symmetry.
Ang dalawang fermion ay hindi maaaring mag-occupy ng parehong estado.
Gayunpaman, para sa isang kadena ng mga qubit, ito ay ganap na naiiba.
Ang dalawang qubit ay maaaring magkasabay na nasa parehong estado,
dahil ang isang qubit ay hindi fermion.
Kailangan na nating makahanap ng paraan para magsalin sa pagitan ng dalawang kadena.
Noong 1928 pa, dalawang mananaliksik, sina Jordan at Wigner,
ay nagpakita na ang mga fermionic operator para sa buong kadena
ay maaaring tumpak na i-represent sa pamamagitan ng mga qubit operator.
Ito ang pinaka-diretso na pagma-map para sa isang quantum computer.
Halimbawa, maaari itong gamitin para i-map ang occupancy
ng isang orbital sa spin ng isang qubit.
Sa praktika, ang pagma-map na ito para sa isang Hamiltonian ay nagreresulta sa isang weighted sum ng mga Pauli operator.
Ito ay isang napakahalagang katotohanan na gusto kong tandaan ninyo,
at babalik tayo rito sa susunod na module kung saan tatalakayin natin
kung paano isinasagawa ang mga variational circuit sa quantum computer.
Ang pagma-map sa itaas ay nangangahulugang kung mayroon tayong, halimbawa,
14 na fermionic operator, imi-map natin ang problema sa 14 na qubit.
Sa kabutihang palad, mayroong mga matalinong paraan para bawasan ang bilang ng mga qubit
at gumamit ng mas kaunting quantum resource para makakuha ng mas magandang performance mula sa quantum computer.
Karaniwan, sa isang molecular na sistema, malalaman natin
ang ilang pisikal na symmetry ng Hamiltonian,
halimbawa, ang kabuuang bilang ng mga elektron ay nakatakda.
Ang impormasyong ito ay maaaring gamitin para bawasan ang laki ng problema
nang hindi nawawala ang anumang kaugnay na impormasyon.
Tinatawag nating active space reduction ang pamamaraang ito.
Nagbibigay-daan ito sa pagbabawas ng bilang ng mga resource, lalo na, bilang ng mga qubit,
bago ang qubit mapping tulad ng Jordan-Wigner transformation.
Ang hakbang na ito ay nagko-calculate ng epektibong Hamiltonian
at nagpapahintulot sa atin na gumamit ng mas kaunting qubit bilang resulta.
Para sa ating halimbawa na may 14 orbital,
binabawasan ng pamamaraang ito ang bilang ng mga qubit sa anim lamang.
Maaari na tayong magpatuloy pa sa mga pagbabawas na ito.
Maaari tayong gumamit ng iba't ibang pagma-map,
na medyo mas kumplikado kaysa sa Jordan-Wigner.
Ang pinakakaraniwang halimbawa ay ang parity mapping.
Ang parity mapping ay hindi nag-ma-map ng occupancy ng mga orbital sa mga qubit,
kundi ang parity ng mga orbital sa mga indibidwal na qubit.
Hindi na tayo papasok sa mga mathematical na detalye dito,
pero ang mahalagang malaman ay naglalaman ang pagma-map na ito ng karagdagang
redundancy na maaaring gamitin para alisin ang dalawa pang qubit.
Kaya ang ating halimbawa na may 14 orbital, bumababa mula 14 qubit
sa 6 na qubit gamit ang active space reduction at pagkatapos ay 4 na qubit
gamit ang two qubit reduction sa parity mapping.
Pag-usapan natin nang maikli ang isa pang transformation.
Isa pang karaniwang ginagamit na pagma-map sa pagitan ng fermionic
at qubit representation ay ang Bravyi-Kitaev transformation.
Ginagamit ng Bravyi-Kitaev transformation ang mga qubit para i-encode ang impormasyon
tungkol sa occupation number at parity ng quantum state.
Pinagsasama ng Bravyi-Kitaev transformation ang occupation number at impormasyon ng parity
para sa isang molecular orbital basis na may laki N,
N na qubit din ang ginagamit.
Gayunpaman, ang impormasyon na nakaimbak sa bawat qubit
ay nagbabago depende kung aling qubit ito.
Ibig sabihin, kapag ang index ng qubit ay even,
iniimbak nito ang occupation number ng katumbas na
orbital number tulad ng sa Jordan-Wigner mapping.
Kapag ang qubit index ay odd, ang qubit ay nag-iimbak ng parity ng partikular na
set ng mga occupation number. Ang Bravyi-Kitaev transformation ang pinaka-epektibo
kapag ang bilang ng mga qubit ay papalapit sa power of two.
Pinagsasama ng Bravyi-Kitaev mapping ang mga kalamangan mula sa Jordan-Wigner
at parity transformation.
Binabawasan nito ang bilang ng mga qubit na kinokontrola ng bawat Hamiltonian term,
Mahalaga ito para sa quantum simulation dahil ang mga term na
kumikilos sa malaking bilang ng mga qubit sa Hamiltonian
ay nangangailangan ng mas mahabang circuit para sa kanilang simulation.
Ibig sabihin nito na ang circuit depth
ay nababawasan gamit ang Bravyi-Kitaev transformation at sa pangkalahatan
ay makakakuha tayo ng mas magandang resulta sa hardware.
Ito ay isang pagpapabuti kumpara sa Jordan-Wigner transformation
na nagresulta sa order of N qubit Hamiltonian.
Kaya, sa video na ito tinalakay natin ang mga paraan para i-map
ang isang fermionic Hamiltonian sa isang qubit Hamiltonian.
Sa susunod, makikita natin kung paano pinakamainam na piliin ang estado
at isang variational form o isang circuit.
Magkita-kita tayo roon.